pour information cette vidéo a été
enregistrée bien avant le confinement et
le corona et elle devait sortir hier
donc je vous la sort aujourd'hui hier à
la déjà été mises en ligne mais on ne
sait pas pourquoi elle n'est pas apparue
dans vos abonnements c'est la majorité
des commentaires qu'on a reçues et
déteste qu'on a effectués youtube ne
sais pas me dire pourquoi donc j'ai
préféré la retirer et l'arrêt ou claude
de nouveau en faisant une petite mise à
jour aussi quelques endroits
voilà bon visionnage salut il ya
quelques jours il ya eu un face à face
de fou sur ces news avec d'en face à
l'info présenté par christine kelly avec
eric zemmour et yann moix alors la
thématique c'était la violence le
mouvement mis tout plein de trucs comme
ça vous êtes plusieurs à avoir suggéré
sur instagram et sur twitter twitter
ouais j'ai ici là et puis ici là puis
j'ai même un tick tock ici je parte au
monde vous m'avez demandé est ce que je
pourrais en faire une petite vidéo
analyse c'est un peu ma spécialité mais
c'est ce qu'on va faire mon gars bien
mou verbal est ce qu'on peut se protéger
de sa tanière est-ce qu'on peut empêcher
quelqu'un de fouet donné je vois ce que
tu veux dire en fait pour faire ça il
faudrait un bpn
un peu comme nord vpn qui sponsorise
cette vidéo d'ailleurs toi qui protège
un peu ça je l'expliquerai plus tard
dans la vidéo mais on va commencer
d'abord par l'analyse loïc générique
simplement un déménagement géographique
c'est une obligation s'en aller car je
crois qu'on peut remonter très loin on
n'a jamais eu 70 ans en guerre
[Musique]
ce générique qui me fait toujours autant
marrer parce que c'est un peu comme le
graphique
il y en a sûrement qui découvrent la
chaîne qui pensent que c'est un
générique au premier degré c'est du
second degré en fait je danse dessus
c'est gênant en parlant de petits
réglages la vidéo que vous voyez à la
pala réparé en fullscreen dans la vidéo
on la regarde depuis mon ordi pourquoi
parce que ses news il n'aime pas trop
donner le droit qu'on utilise comme ça
des bouts de leurs vidéos qu'on les
mette à forcer pour éviter un peu le
strike je vous rappelle rapidement que
pour cette analyse non verbal je vais
piocher mes outils dans plein de
domaines différents dont des dips je
peux utiliser le lien 17e science donc
tout ce que je dis c'est à prendre avec
des pincettes mais départ cette géante
tu vois le truc c'était un homard géant
à vous je ne prends pas parti je n'ai
pas toutes les données
ça reste il des interprétations
possibles
voilà la musique qui fait peur de
remarquer les chaînes d'info c'est
toujours la musique qui fait peur que la
musique il tape truc de torsion quoi
pourquoi des moucherons chez - bonsoir
testing il n'est pas incroyable ce face
à face quand même en vrai cesser ses
émaux et yann moix que c'est à dire que
déjà le indépendamment mériterait une
vidéo analyse de 2 tu sais c'est pas
vraiment là on se dit tiens on va on va
les mettre ensemble et on va rester le
plus neutre possible
alors est-ce qu'on a des crispations
détention des choses comme ça n'ont pas
trop crime un chroniqueur réalisateur
vous avez obtenu de nombreux prix pour
vos ouvrages on peut citer koala comment
qu'on a vue d'un assaut un sourire qu'il
a voulu contenir
ah oui c'est ça haha tu es grosse très
fort quant à lui fait son apologie de
départ de
voilà tout ce que vous avez peur d'être
réalisateur vous avez de machin vous
avez tous il a le petit sourire de
satisfaction qui monte
esi mais n'en faut pas que je donne
cette image ça dure pas longtemps c'est
vraiment une seconde
enfin c'est pas une seconde justement
ces quelques images c'est juste là esi a
non non non non non non faut pas qu'on
montre à quel point c'est satisfaisant
je sais que ce que on dit de moi parce
que j'aime bien tu m'aimes qui ont connu
1940 45 et j'allais même dire ceux qui
ont connu 1968 ont connu la vraie
violence ma grand-mère 94 ans a connu la
violence et celle d'aujourd'hui l'a fait
doucement rigoler ah bon alors ça ça
c'est plus de l'analyse verbal du sort
ce truc là de dire ma grand mère qu à 94
ans qui a connu toutes ces violences là
que je viens de citer cela fait
doucement rigoler ça permet en fait de
pas se faire attaquer nuit sur cette
opinion forte de dire aujourd'hui votre
violence ça me fait bien marrer les gars
ce qui serait très violents pour le coup
ci lui disais ça et prenez partis
là-dessus mais en fait du coup pour pas
se faire attaquer lui parce qu'attention
on parle de deux mecs très intelligent
quand même hein il des portes possibles
ressenti sur celui de sa grand mère
potentielle
tu vois et là on se dit bah ouais parce
que elle a connu des guerres des trucs
des machins et tout ce qui permet lui de
quand même distillé une opinion sans
cela rapatriés sur la négative sur lui
quoi aujourd'hui la révolution les plus
possible parce que le gouvernement a si
vous voulez intégrer 10 g il a une
grande ouverture aux corps régulière à
eric et moi ça veut dire en tout cas je
ne sais pas s'ils vont se prendre la
tête ou pas j'ai pas regardé encore mais
ça veut dire que lui il est plutôt en
déclarations amicales envers lui je sais
pas si ça va être un débat ou s'ils vont
être plutôt de ce que je vois là je
tendance à penser qu'ils vont se
rejoindre sur les sujets et toute
possibilité de révolution pour la
diffuser sous forme de réformes
il ya en gros de france ça c'est marrant
la position des est mort quand il ya
deux mois que s'ils parlent
le fait qu'ils soient français est fermé
comme ça avec les mouvements quand même
de oui et cette attention il n'y a pas
de crispation particulière il ya juste
les tous les signes d'une tension de
concentration donc en fait ils en train
d'absorber aussi tout ce que dit yann
moix pour le passé dans sa moulinette
intellectuelle et de se dire est ce que
je suis d'accord avec ça parce que on
voit que yann moix est en train
d'établir
pensez à ce moment là donc lui-même il
en train de voir les chemins qu'ils
utilisent donc ce n'est pas encore très
clair et lui a besoin de savoir ce qu'on
va être d'accord ou pas d'accord et si
on n'est pas d'accord il faut que
j'argumente là dessus et si on est
d'accord il faut aussi que je donne ma
propre opinion mais il est vraiment une
position ne de j'écoute et je vais voir
tu sais quand tu es quelqu'un qui dit
écoute faut que je demande un truc je
vais t'expliquer et de et ouaté comme ça
tu fais ouais d'accord ok d'accord est
en fait la question si tu veux en venir
ou en fait pour que je puisse reprendre
ma position c'est exactement ce qui se
passe là sur le visage et c'est pour ça
que ça c'est pas une fermeture à un
moment donné c'est juste un repli pour
bien se concentrer
ce sont des avocats ce sont des notables
qui ont fait sa révolution et il ya
celle de 1793 sait comment ça le
démangeait là j'ai bien envie de parler
et donc la voyez le changement de
position qu'on a eue au delà des mots
justes dans le non verbal on va parler
de ce moment là toute la concentration
là commence à comprendre où est ce qu'il
veut aboutir ça fait tilt et là il a sa
propre opinion
et là il se met on voit il se libère de
toute la concentration parce qu'ils
voudraient réagir on voit qu'il le voit
et je pense que là il se dit juste
intérêts manger juste terminée et il ya
celle de miss élues fait et vous avez
raison sur un point parce qu'il a vu
qu'il était en négation
donc il ya une vraie écoute non verbal
des 2 1 et il va clôturer mais lui reste
en position de j'aimerais prendre la
parole et je vais puisque c'est
intéressant ce que ce que dit ce que dit
yann moix parce que je suis d'accord
avec le début et pas du tout avec la fin
je vous explique en grande de la cession
n'avait vu un il vient juste de dire je
suis d'accord avec le début et pas avec
la fin on part pour elle ment il y avait
il y avait rien de spécial par rapport à
ça là on a juste se passe comment de
lèvres c'est pas de l'agacement c'est ça
traduit plus sain en fait je pense que
dans la démarche consciente ou
inconsciente
yann moix voulait être d'accord avec
zemmour est d'ailleurs quand il l'a
senti ce nom il a fait mais comme ça
comme c'est comme si vous voulez
compléter pour dire tu vas voir on va
être d'accord au final et la salle la
mère d'un petit peu qui ce qu'ils se
soient pas rapprochés en fait qui n'est
pas visé aussi juste qu'il aurait
souhaité enfin une petite pause ici
parce que je pense qu'on a à peu près au
milieu de la vidéo
je vais en profiter quand même pour
revenir sur norvez pnc quoi tu es là et
tu te promènes 6
internet a je me promène sur la toile
bon ok hélas imagine par exemple il ya
un méchant pirate qui veut qu'il veut
prendre tes données personnelles il à
eelv
je suis le méchant pirate ça se fois
bien je suis allemand et a de fait ah
non non mes données personnelles
ah ah je vous ai bienvenus ouais ça
s'excite à paneuropéenne imagine
maintenant tu es sur internet et tu te
promènes déjà tu dis elle j'aimerais
bien qu'on sache pas trop où est ce que
je suis localiser et puis j'aimerais
bien que être protégé aussi de toutes
mes données mais il faudrait que les
serveurs soient très très rapide pour ça
et de grande qualité et latin bonheur
qu'il dit oui mais tu n'es pas protégé à
un tapin salut je suis nerveux pn et je
vais protéger été donné à l'esma aller
voir le monsieur parce que je suis un
rouleur allemand quand le pirate fowler
allemand ah ouais et bien en vrai et
c'est lui là bas
ah je suis censé être le monsieur qui a
je vais chercher tes données mais mais
tu n'es pas vraiment là à aups excuse
moi c'est toujours lui tenant de paix n
1 en vrai c'est le mec qui est là-bas
sur son sur son skateboard à l'autre
bout du monde
ah cool je vais quand même pouvoir aller
prendre ces trucs même si donc il
ressemble pas à la description que j'ai
avec lui mais non c'est pas lui non plus
à excuse moi c'est toujours en fait
c'est le mec qui est juste là derrière
moi et tous à je vais bientôt
et comme ça y est c'est pas possible en
fait il des regrets puisque nos répète
comme ça ils protègent
il protège toi il le cache là c'est pas
lui là s'est il ne trouvera jamais
n'aurait pn pour faire très court je
voulais dit ils ont des serveurs très
rapide ça permet aussi de connecter
jusqu'à six appareils avec le même
compte aucune de vos données sont
conservées ils ont même fait un audit
pour prouver ça il ya une bande passante
illimitée etc etc ce qui fait qu'ils ont
été élus meilleurs vpn en 2018 et en
2019 et vous pouvez avoir 70 % de
réduction sur nos rues pleines soit 3
euros 10 par mois soit très cher et en
bonus un mois supplémentaire gratuit en
passant par mon lien voilà qui
disponible dans la description avec le
code fabien olicard c'est très facile à
se rappeler c'est le nom de cette chaîne
la merci l'armée pn qui n'a même pas
tirer sur les assaillants
mais c'est une grande querelle je ne
crois pas à la thèse des furets sur les
deux révolutions la gentille la méchante
c'est que je ne crois pas je pense que
la terreur commence tout de suite et que
l'afo la révolution française et
violente par essence juste là en fait on
a toutes les règles du jeu je pense
qu'ils vont traduire l'émission donc là
on voit il veut intervenir en fait sur
ce qu'il dit sur lequel il n'est pas
d'accord mais en fait ils en train
d'extrapoler quelque chose et on voit
tout
l'agacement et ce positionnement en fait
très droit de mec qui prend le lead en
fait et lui habitué en plus à ça il est
vraiment habitué à exprimer les idées
fortes et où on lui donne plus d avis
habituellement lui les incarnent
on voit que lui il est que yann moix que
c'est un peu un peu déçu par à part ça
en disant non mais ça vraiment que je
voulais dire en fait c'est ça que ça
traduit là et envoie le moment où il va
gagner tu vois là il demande
l'autorisation c'est quand même un geste
très fort c'est une demande
d'autorisation oui non mais c'est parce
que s'il vous plaît je voulais dire est
là on continue puisque moi je te dis oui
mais vraiment je voulais rajouter
et voilà et là vous l'avez juste vue là
le moment où il lâche et je pense que ça
va donner le ton de leurs échanges
c'est le moment où vous voyez ça
s'apprend demi seconde ou en fait ils
baissent le doigt il acquiesce de la
tête pour dire oui d'accord la tête est
légèrement baissé ce qui dans le monde
animal y a toujours été un signe de
soumission et il se mord la bouche pour
se dire en fait je ne vais pas parler
regardez maintenant
c'est fou quand on a le temps de
regarder en détail toutes les
interprétations qu'on peut faire bien
sûr que non
et il y a des choses pas qu'on fasse la
guerre pas rendu mais je vais y venir
ça c'est terrible parce qu'en fait il
referme la discussion ait dit non
il a il a son regard est toujours sans
son petit agacement mais a assez lille
regardez la tête de yann moix quand il
reçoit ça et il fait ce mouvement avec
la main enfin du coup ça va être comme
ça
oui mais voilà comme ça pour lui dire on
passe à autre chose c'est ça qui lui
envoient quoi et on passe à autre chose
avec la promesse potentiel d'y revenir
plus tard mais c'est mort il a repris le
lead enfin de lanaye sur un match sur ce
moment là c'est la femme du mouvement de
la main et là tu vois juste la petite
protection le recul le visage baissé
c'est à dire c'est la violence qui est
né de l'immigration et des migrants en
deux mots je m'explique et je vous
laisse répond je j'ai lu un jour c'est
très intéressant
bon pour l'instant yann moix garder sa
position d' écoute et lui vient de faire
sa quatrième démonstration quand même
donc ça commence à être long et il sait
qu'à ce moment là il devrait un peu
relais c'est la parole il va anticiper
ça il est très aguerris c'est à dire
c'est la violence qui est né de
l'immigration été réitérée en 2000 je
m'explique et je vous laisse répondre
est là lui qui pensait qu'ils allaient
avoir la parole il le renvoie encore en
dix ans mais ça va être après c'est son
truc depuis le départ ça va être après à
toi et regarde et comment il va recevoir
le truc encore une fois regardez bien
c'est maintenant où je m'explique et je
vous laisse répondre
ap on repasse lève pour pas parler on se
re recul juste on a le menton qui se
lève donc on est un petit peu défiance
c'est à dire que la même lui trouve que
c'est abusé
et c'est ce qui renvoie par là de
n'exagère pas je j'ai lu un jour mais ce
qui est très intéressant alors la main
devant la bouche en ont fait ça en
général quand on a envie de s'empêcher
de parler c'est incroyable quand même
parce que depuis le départ il l'a
tellement eric zemmour manipuler yann
moix
il a réussi à lui faire mettre un
cadenas sur sa bouche maintenant pour
qu'il ne laisse parler si on regardait
le temps de parole là depuis nous on
n'est qu'à sept minutes de vidéo il ya
eu entre eux et moi yann moix zemmour a
défoncé son temps de parole
il a verrouillé yann moix on a aussi vu
la bande à baader extérieur ya jamais de
gens de 49 ans
tout ça ça lui va parce que ça augmente
son propos lent et là on est passé au
mais je n'écoute pas ce qu'ils disent je
m'en fous un peu
mais en fait ce qui est marrant c'est de
voir ok ça je prends ces je prends ça je
prends ça je prends et dès que j'ai
entendu le mot mais on a le changement
de position regarder car oui oui oui non
oui ce sont des gens je dis oui mais je
voudrais peut-être qu'une forme de
déménagement et la l'immigrant ce que
j'appelle moi les exilés ou c'est pas
simplement à à la vu comment il est
d'aider mieux là dessus c'est à dire que
juste à ce moment là et même là on a un
tout petit peu pas en l'envoyant c'est à
dire que lui distingué il vient de dire
je crois de forme de migrants se grosso
modo qui choisissent d'aller dans un
autre pays mais ceux qui fuient leur
pays parce qu'ils n'ont pas d'autres
choix
et sur cette deuxième catégorie il lui
envoie comme ça avec un peu de recul
en regardant ce que ça va pour convoquer
vois ça provoque le le dédain cassure
rapide mais pas si rapide que ça il s'en
cache pas simplement un déménagement
géographique
si tu es pas content là et se redresse
on sait qu'il va reprendre le lead
obligation parce que c'est une question
de vie ou de mort je distingue donc ce
chez oui c'est non il ne cache pas et
moi c'est très simple
peut-être s'arrêter là ouais ça va faire
un petit peu long parce que si
j'extrapole ça veut dire que notre vidéo
elle ferait une heure et demie pour
traiter tout le face à face ça va être
un petit peu long le reste si on faisait
de l'analyse verbale ce serait
intéressant pour confronter les opinions
et/ou mais ce qui était intéressant
c'était de voir comment allait se passer
le jeu entre yann moix et à eghezée
moore de voir comment l'un se
positionner par al bras l'aude je pense
qu'on a eu la réponse à ça le qui vous a
vu la course a dit moi dans les
commentaires si vous voulez qu'on aille
plus loin dans ce débat là mais on peut
aussi aller toucher maintenant d'autres
vidéos de trop et que dans tous les
domaines comme d'habitude
dites moi dans les commentaires quels
sont les analyses que vous voulez pour
la suite dit nous vraiment peu se défont
gala entre les sujets abonnez vous
activer la cloche c'est important laïque
et si vous aimez cette série de vidéos
vous avez des dernières dates de mon
spectacle en tournée dans la description
avec la date du zénith on n'oublie pas
le zénith de paris on prend sa place pas
trop tu as appris en aura plus et encore
un grand merci à
noren soutenir de vidéos avec ce
partenariat
je vous rappelle que vous pouvez avoir
70 % de réduction sur norvégiennes soit
3 euros 10 par mois avec un mois bonus
supplémentaires gratuits en passant par
mon lien disponible en descriptions et
le code fabien olicard mon prénom est
mon nom de famille d'affilée en
minuscules
j'ai tout dit loïc tu me sembles bien on
vous aime ah oui non très bientôt à ciao